آه.
لما تنظر للقدرات الموجودة اليوم، أعتقد إنه سؤال مهم جداً تقول
طيب ما هي خارطة الطريق، يعني قديش
هذه الأنظمة أحسن
وقديش راح تصبح أكثر تعقيداً
وقديش ستكون تعقيداً
الـ circuit اللي نقدر ننفذه
وعشان هذا طورنا مقياساً مهم جداً
اسمه الحجم الكمي
ممكن تقرأ أو تسمع أحياناً في الصحافة الشعبية
عن عدد الـ qubit وتعرف
وهذا كمقياس للتقدم
بقولك بصراحة إن
مجرد عدد الـ qubit في الجهاز مش
مقياس جيد للتقدم
التقدم لازم يتقاس بـ
مستوى تعقيد الـ circuit اللي تقدر تنفذه
الـ qubit وهذه الأجهزة الجيدة مش مثالية اليوم
وفيها أخطاء تنشأ من اقتران
النظام مع العالم الخارجي
قوة الـ qubit بحد ذاتها
من التشابك الكمي وهذه الخصائص
هي نفسها اللي تخليها قوية
وحساسة في نفس الوقت للتداخل
والاتصال مع العالم الخارجي
يعني لازم تخفض معدل الخطأ
وأنت في نفس الوقت بتزيد عدد الـ qubit
وهذا ما يتوضح هنا
اللي فعلاً تبي تعمله هو تتحرك بشكل قطري
والحجم الكمي هو مقياس يجمع
هذين المقياسين مع اعتبارات إضافية مهمة